The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK, OK.
Let's get started.
Going to go right
into the lesson.
Last day we started looking
at kinetics, which was the
description of rate and
mechanism of chemical reactions.
We looked at the general rate
law, which shows us that the
instant change in concentration
of species i
goes as the instant
concentration.
So rate is proportional
to concentration.
And the order of reaction
is shown here as n and
proportionality constant
is the rate constant k.
So we saw that we can make the
rate of reaction increase by
increasing the concentration
in the reactor.
We saw there was a second way
to increase the rate of
reaction, and that was to
raise the temperature.
And this is the Arrhenius
relationship that shows that
the rate constant changes with
temperature according to this
exponential relationship.
In the denominator, we have the
product of the Boltzmann
constant and the absolute
temperature, which is a
measure of the ambient thermal
energy that's available to
promote reaction.
And in the numerator we have a
barrier energy, which we call
the activation energy.
We'll say a little bit more
about that today.
And the constant of
proportionality out here is A,
which is in honor of Arrhenius,
who first
annunciated the law.
So what I want to do today is to
look at some common orders
of reactions.
So we're going to look at
the values of n that are
encountered in not
insignificant number of reactions.
So let's start with
the simplest one.
The simplest one
is first order.
First order reactions.
That means n equals 1 in this
rate law expression.
And here's an example of
something that we could use.
The decomposition of
N2O5 into NO2.
And gives us half a
mole of oxygen.
And we can write this rate law
in terms of the rate of
disappearance of N2O5.
So I can write minus
d by dt of--
I'm going to use square brackets
to indicate the
concentration--
of N2O5.
And this has been measured.
You can't predict this from the
stoichiometry of the equation.
You have to measure this, and
on the basis of measurements
it's found that the rate of
change of N2O5 goes as the
concentration of N2O5.
And there's a constant
out here.
The rate constant.
So just to make the point, I'm
going to put a 1 here.
Meaning that n equals 1 and
that's why this is a
first-order reaction.
But this is messy.
There's too many characters
here.
So I'm going to compress this
and give myself a nicer font,
so I'm going to let the
concentration of N2O5, just in
this expression, just be c.
Lowercase c.
That way I can speed
this thing up.
So I can rewrite this expression
here as minus dc by
dt equals k times c.
All right.
And so we know what this
is going to look like.
They all look like this.
If we plot concentration versus
temperature we expect
to have the maximum value
of this at time zero.
So at time zero I
start off with--
if you want c-star or c max--
and you know, this
thing attenuates.
But I can't look at that and
decide whether it's first
order or not.
The only thing the eye
can really tell
is a straight line.
So what I want to do is I want
to modify this thing.
I want to map c into
some f of c.
And I want to map t
into some g of t.
So that if I plot f versus
g, I get a straight line.
And then I can take one look at
that and go, bingo, this is
first order.
Or not.
Or maybe it's first order and
the data are very noisy.
So what we'll do is
we're going to
integrate that equation.
So I'm going to play with
this a little bit.
So I'm going to transpose.
I'll get minus dc over
c equals kdt.
And then I can integrate this
because I know at time 0, t
equals 0, c equals
some value--
I can call it c-star
or c naught--
and at any arbitrary time later,
I can go down that
curve and put some value of time
and then I'll end up with
some arbitrary value
of concentration c.
And I know there's some math
people in the audience who are
probably horrified that the
limits and the integrand are
both the same.
So I'll put a little tilde
here that way I
don't go to math jail.
So now I'm not integrating c.
If I wanted to be a pedant and
really make the math instead
of me enslaving the math, the
math enslaving me, watch this.
What I could do is I
could make this a
carrier variable, s.
You know what I'm talking
about now, right?
But let's get really crazy.
This is how bad the
math can get.
You can do this in
a chemistry book.
Let's use some Greek.
So I'll make this
d xi over xi.
Now I've totally left the
class behind, but it's
mathematically correct.
What we will do is we'll
put the t back and put
a tilde over it.
And now everybody is happy, and
heaven forbid, the student
might even understand
the lesson.
All right.
So we do that and
what do we get?
The integral of dc over c
is a natural log of c.
This'll be natural log of c
equals natural log of c
naught minus kt.
OK, so integrating this thing
gives us this expression.
And that means if I plot the
natural log of c versus time I
should get a straight line.
And furthermore, the slope
is equal to minus k.
So here's an example that's
taken from your book.
It happens to be another
first-order reaction and it
shows the decomposition
of cisplatin.
This is a compound that's used
in certain cancer treatments.
And you can cisplatin hydrolyzes
to form this
monster cation plus
a chloride.
And it turns out that the rate
of decomposition of cisplatin
is first order.
Will you look at that curve?
That purple line?
I don't know what that means.
But watch.
If I instead plot the natural
logarithm of the concentration
of cisplatin as a function of
time, you get a nice straight
line, and furthermore,
the value of k is
obvious from the slope.
So this is an indication of the
power of taking the proper
order of reaction and
then using it in--
if you'll pardon the pun--
straightening things out.
And a couple other things
worth noting.
I mentioned at the end of last
day, radioactive decay.
Even though radioactive decay
is not a chemical reaction--
it has to do with nuclear
phenomena-- and we know
chemistry is restricted to
the life and times of the
electron, we don't go
into the nucleus.
We simply know there's something
in there, there's
neutrons, protons, and a whole
bunch of other particles.
But chemistry is about
the life and
times of the electron.
Radioactive decay turns
out to be first order.
It's good to know that
because then you can
appreciate what goes on.
So for example, you could
take something like the
decomposition of uranium-238.
One of its decompositions
gives you
thorium-234 plus helium.
And it turns out that this is
first order, which means that
if you were to take a plot
of the natural log of the
concentration of uranium
versus time, you get a
straight line.
And this slope would be the
k, the rate constant.
But it turns out that the
nuclear chemists, nuclear
engineers, prefer not to talk
about the rate of reaction in
terms of k.
But instead, they like to
use the inverse of k,
which is the half-life.
So instead, express k
through half-life.
And the half-life, as the name
implies, is the time it takes
to decrease the concentration
of the species by half.
So if I start off here at c1 and
down here I have c2 equals
1/2 c1, then this is the time
it takes to cut the
concentration in half.
So through half-life--
and we can go through this
equation here, just put c
naught over 2 and do a little
bit of manipulation, you'll
end up with the natural log
of 2 divided by the rate
constant, which is 0.693
divided by k.
So you can see that there's
a direct relationship.
It turns out that the half-life
for this reaction is
4 1/2 billion years.
So that means after 4 1/2
billion years the
concentration has gone down to
a half, but even then it's
probably not safe for the
kids to go out and play.
So you really need to think
about it in this way.
So here it is shown
in your textbook.
Concentration as a
function of time.
They could have plotted it log
linear, then you would have
ended up with this.
But anyways, they're chemists,
so what can you expect.
So here it is.
Here it goes down to a half, and
then this is a half of a
half as a quarter.
It's the same time interval.
And then half of a quarter is
an eighth, and it's the same
time interval.
So you get the sense.
And the most important thing
is the half-life is
independent of concentration.
It doesn't matter what the
starting concentration is-- if
you know what the half-life is,
you know how much time it
takes to get to a half.
And you know enough math.
What if I said, well, what if I
didn't want to go to a half?
What if I wanted to go to 10%?
Well, you can figure out how
to modulate half-life into
tenth-life.
That's trivial.
But the book, being a chemistry
book, will show you
a table in which they give
half-life values for orders of
reactions other than 1.
And it's stupid because except
in the case of first order
reactions, the value the
half-life is a function of the
concentration.
So what good is a constant
that's variable?
I don't know, but I didn't
write the book.
The only time I care about
half-life is in the case of a
first order reaction, which
is when you have
nuclear decay for sure.
All right.
So that's enough about
first order.
Let's go look at second-order
reactions.
So here's an example also
taken from the book.
So second-order reaction, which
means that n equals 2 in
the rate law expression.
n equals 2 in the rate
law expression.
And the example that
they gave was NO2.
See, look.
We went from N2O5 to NO2.
And then we can keep the
decomposition going.
NO2 goes to NO plus O2.
And again, I'm going to let, in
this case, c will equal the
concentration of NO2.
And what you end up with in
this case is, if you go
through the similar analysis,
you get minus dc by dt.
It's been measured that the rate
of loss of NO2 goes as
the square of its
concentration.
So this is based on experimental
evidence.
It's not because this is a 2.
This is not.
Please pay attention here.
This 2 is not the consequences
of the stoichiometry.
This 2 was determined
experimentally.
I could have just written
this reaction NO2 goes
to NO plus 1/2 O2.
That doesn't make this
first order, does it?
Experimentally in
the laboratory.
All right.
So now what we can do is we
can integrate this thing.
And so we'll get minus the--
let's do it this way.
Boards are cheap, so let's jump
down to the next one.
So now I can then put minus
the integral of dc tilde--
cross multiply--
so dc tilde over c tilde
squared equals k,
the integral dt tilde.
And we can integrate this from
zero to some time, and this
will go from c naught to
some concentration.
And that will give us 1
over c equals 1 over
c naught plus kt.
So this is now the new, improved
way of mapping c
versus t into f of
c versus g of t.
So f of c as 1 over c, which
means now if I plot 1 over c
versus time, I'll get
a straight line.
In this case, it's got
positive slope.
It's got positive slope,
so that's what it's
going to look like.
And this is k.
So if I take our data set and
I plot it like this, then I
can make sense of it.
And I think we've got
some data here.
So here's the data from
this decomposition.
And again, what do you see?
A line that attenuates.
Can you look at that line?
Can you tell that line is second
order, whereas the
other one that looks like
this was first order?
Of course not.
The only way you can tell
his to fit it into some
linearizing function.
So look at that.
What they've done, that's
the least squares fit.
They plugged it into a least
squares fitting equation.
You can fit a straight line
through anything.
It doesn't matter.
But what's that mean?
I don't know.
So here's the log.
This is really important--
look carefully.
So somebody took these data and
then plotted them as the
natural log, which is what you
do if it's first order.
And look at what happens--
it gets a lot better but it's
still not a straight line.
But if you were in a hurry,
you'd just say, force the fit.
You'll get a straight line and
you'll assigned the value of k
to it and party on.
And it's wrong.
So now let's try this.
Beta.
1 over c versus time.
So what do we get from that?
I get two things.
First of all, the fact that
it's a straight line means
that it confirms n equals 2 and
the slope of that line is
the value of k.
So in point of fact, what I've
been doing here is teaching
you how to determine the
rate of reaction.
So let's do it.
Let's codify this.
So determination of
order of reaction.
So in other words, the way the
story goes is I give you a
data set that looks
like this--
pardon me.
I give you a data set that looks
like this and I say,
determine the order
of reaction.
So there's two general
ways to do this.
The first one is called
the integral method.
And that's what we've been
doing up until now.
The integral method, it's called
the integral method
because it's using the
integrated form
of the radio question.
See?
This is the integrative form.
Hence, the integral method,
and it's trial and error.
That's what we did.
Trial and error.
But we don't say trial and error
because we're at MIT.
So what do we say?
We have a lofty way.
What's the lofty way of saying
trial and error?
By inspection.
Never tell anybody you do things
by trial and error.
We don't do trial and error.
By inspection.
It's $50,000 a year.
It's what you get.
OK, so here's what I do.
I'm impatient, so I
try n equals 1.
If I get a straight line
on the log plot, good.
If not, I try n equals 2.
If I got a straight line
on 1 over c, good.
If not, go to the second
way of determining.
I give up.
Won't waste my time.
It's a two strikes and
you're out thing.
So what's the second method?
The second method is called
the differential method.
The differential method.
And this is fun because it's
data fitting and it gets into
some nice detail.
So what I want to do is
to define the rate.
What's the rate?
The rate is over here.
Minus dc by dt, right?
You see up in the top left
corner the rate law.
Minus dc by dt.
I'm going to call
that positive r.
I'm just compress-- this
is like French cooking.
I started with this.
Look at all those fonts.
Then I compressed it down
to c, and now I
compressed it even more.
It's just so much information
compressed in
that little r there.
Poor little r.
All right.
So now, let's rewrite the
rate law expression.
So that's r equals
kc to the n.
There's the rate law expression
written very compact.
And now I'm going to take the
logarithm of both sides.
So taking the log of both sides,
I can write natural log
of r, the log of a product
is the sum of the log.
So that's going to be natural
log of k plus the
log of, da, da, da.
n log c.
And I don't care what kind
of logarithms you use.
You can make this log base c.
You can make it log base 10.
If you're feeling like you
want solidarity with the
Mayans, you can make
it log base 5.
I don't care.
But make them the same.
Make them the same.
And then what happens?
Well, let me show you.
So let's say we've got our data,
start off with this data
set like so.
So this is concentration
versus time and
we end up with this.
It comes down, down,
down, attenuates.
Remember, what are we
trying to do here?
We're trying to take this data
set and figure out, what is
the value of n?
We're trying to determine n.
So what this thing says is.
if I make a plot of r versus c
so that it's on a log scale,
so if I plot log r versus log c,
the slope is going to be n.
So how do I take c versus
t and construct log
r verses log c?
That's what we're going to do.
So here we are and I can start
here that at time zero.
This is time zero.
That's the slope, right?
The slope here is the rate.
So slope, I'm going to
call it r naught.
Because that's the time--
it's dc by dt r naught
at t equals t naught.
But there's no t on here.
So what am I going to put?
It's when t equals t naught
and c equals c naught.
So now I'm going to take some
colored chalk and we're going
to show you how to
construct this.
So I've got the slope by taking
minus dc by dt here.
So I'm going to take this value,
r naught, and this
value, c naught--
I want to gang them together,
I'll bring over here and put
them right out here-- so
now I've got r naught.
Well, actually I should put the
abscissa first. So this is
going to be c naught r naught.
And now let's do it again.
So we'll come down here
to some later time.
Let's call this t1.
And at t1 the concentration has
fallen to c1, and I take
the slope of this.
Why am I taking the slope?
Because it's dc by dt.
That's what the rate is.
So here now I've got slope
r1 at c equals c1.
r versus c.
Forget time.
Time doesn't belong here.
So take those.
It's a lower concentration,
so it's kind of
like a lower energy.
So we'll take a lower
wavelength here.
So r1 and c1 come over here.
c1, r1.
We'll do one more.
Three's a charm.
Come up to here.
This is t2.
Concentration has fallen to
c2, and I've got a slope.
You see how the slope is getting
less and less steep?
Because the rate loss says
the concentration
falls, the rate falls.
So this is slope r2
at c equals c2.
That's lower energy.
So I'll get the orange.
Or maybe this is fuchsia.
So we'll take this one.
And this will put these
two together and bring
them in like so.
And this is now c2, r2. too
And what's this thing say?
Take the slope.
Look, it's a log, log plot.
If you've got physical data and
you don't get a straight
line on a log, log plot,
you're incompetent.
You're a complete idiot.
All right?
There it is.
And the slope here is n.
And where it intersection,
obviously I can't get a
negative number, so just allow
me to fix this just a wee bit.
So there's the axis, and where
it hits the axis, this is now
log k isn't it?
So I determine the order
of reaction.
Good.
So now you know how to do it and
you'll get some practice
if you work the homework.
All right.
A couple more things to say
and then we're done.
So last thing, we talked about
increasing the rate of
reaction by increasing the
temperature and increasing the
concentration.
There's one more thing
we can do.
And what we can do is use a
catalyst. Increase rate by use
of
catalyst. OK.
How does the catalyst work?
Well, let's go back to
this diagram here.
Where we've got, this is called
the extent of reaction.
Some kind of reaction
coordinate.
And over here we had some kind
of energy coordinate.
We had this energy coordinate.
Remember, we had this thing?
This silly thing here?
So this is the reactions.
And this is the product.
And we reasoned that the
activation energy ea is
sitting here.
And we saw with the box, you had
to get a box up onto its
ear, otherwise it wouldn't
fall over and so on.
And there's a finite amount,
finite fraction of the
Maxwell-Boltzmann
distribution.
So if we plot energy and the
number of particles in the
distribution have of given
energy, we get something that
looks like this.
Tails off.
And we said that out
here we have the
fracture under this line.
This is the fraction that has
the energy to jump over the
activation barrier.
So fa is the--
f is the activated, is the
fraction activated.
And those are the only
ones that can
participate in the reaction.
These other ones can't surmount
the activation barrier.
Now, what the catalyst
does is it lowers
the activation barrier.
Catalyst lowers the activation
barrier.
It doesn't change
the n points.
The n points represent the
energy state of the reactants
and the energy state
of the products.
What the catalyst does
is it finds a
low-energy barrier pathway.
A low-energy barrier pathway,
which on this curve would mean
that if this energy is lower,
then the fraction of any
distribution that has the
requisite amount of energy is
much higher.
Can you see the area?
The blue area is much, much
greater than the white area.
So that means that this
fa catalyzed--
I'm just going to
write cat here--
fa catalyzed is much greater
than fa in the absence of a
catalyst. And that promotes.
What's an example of it?
Well, in an automobile
catalyst one of their
reactions we're trying to
promote is unburned
hydrocarbons.
There's some unburned gasoline
that comes out in the form of
carbon monoxide.
What we want to do is
convert the carbon
monoxide to carbon dioxide.
And this occurs on the catalyst
and I'll show you
more of this at the end
of the lecture.
But these are both gas molecules
and they're zooming
through space.
And if they're going to react
with one another, they really
need to somehow move almost on
parallel lines so they get
close enough to each other for
a long enough period of time
that they can start thinking
about lower energy state.
And say, well, gee, if we break
this bond and form a new
bond, it's going to go to--
you've got to get to know each
other, go have a few drinks,
and da, da, da.
So it's not happening.
In the gas phase it
doesn't happen.
So what we do instead is
we provide a service.
This is the catalyst. The
catalyst is a solid surface
and the CO sits down
next to another CO.
They sit down and now they're
in place long enough in the
right orientation to then form
CO2 and then desorb.
So this is how the
catalyst assists.
We call this-- especially,
imagine if
it's the other way--
what if this carbon monoxide
molecule is turn around so
that the two carbons
are side by side.
That's not going to promote the
reaction at all because
this thing's got to whip
around and so on.
This is a.
Bad orientation
And what's the Greek idea
for orientation?
It's stereos.
That's what stereophonic
sound is.
If I close my eyes,
the two speakers
give me spatial rendition.
So this concept here, where
things are backwards and
they're not the right place.
It's called steric hindrance.
This is steric hindrance.
One of the functions of a
catalyst is to combat steric
hindrance and put things
in their most favorable
orientation to facilitate
reaction.
So what are characteristics
of the catalyst?
The catalyst needs to have the
following characteristics--
first of all, it has to have an
affinity for the reactants.
In this case, the CO.
It has to have an affinity
for carbon monoxide.
Affinity for reactants, so
they'll be attracted to the
catalyst.
But there's a second
piece here.
If the catalyst doesn't get rid
of the CO2, can you see
that after a very short period
of time, the surface of the
catalyst will be covered with
carbon dioxide and then the
reaction starves.
It's choked.
So it has to have a disaffinity
for the products.
Disaffinity for the products.
And in the real world, such as
in the gas exhaust stream of a
car, it's not just
carbon monoxide.
There's all kinds of other stuff
going on in there, and
so the third thing that the
catalyst needs to have is
selectivity.
So it doesn't get distracted
by other reactions.
And selectivity, most important
when you have a
mixture of all sorts
of other species.
So that's what the
catalyst does.
Now there's one more thing.
Just one second.
Perfect.
Gotcha just in time.
So one more thing here.
One more thing.
We've shown what happens
when you catalyze.
So I'm going to put this.
This is ea under the influence
of catalysis.
OK.
This is the e of the catalyst.
There are other substances that
can retard the reaction.
These are called inhibitors.
And what's an inhibitor do?
It does the complimentary
action.
So it raises the activation
barrier.
So this is ea under the
influence of inhibitor.
And what's the value of that?
Well, if you buy some antifreeze
for use in the
automobile cooling system.
If you read carefully the label,
it's not just ethylene
glycol, and water, 50/50
volume percent.
There are other additives.
What are those additives?
Some of them are called
inhibitors.
Oh, I didn't spell this right.
No wonder you looked
so puzzled.
I thought you didn't understand
the concept.
Inhibitor.
So it inhibits the reaction.
What's going on?
You've got the iron or aluminum
block of the engine,
you got the water pump.
It's taking heat away from the
engine, you're heating
everything up, stirring
it around.
It's a perfect environment
for enhancing corrosion.
And we don't want the cooling
system to act as the corrosion
system for the engine.
And so we add components to the
antifreeze too reduce the
rate of corrosion, to
lengthen the service
lifetime of the vehicle.
And so what does the
inhibitor do?
It raises the activation barrier
for the corrosion
reaction and thereby reduces
its rate of reaction
substantially.
So this is inhibited.
OK, so this is catalyzed, this
is inhibited, and you can see
that the fraction of active
species over the activation
barrier, under the influence
of inhibition, is much less
than the fraction otherwise.
There's a time and a place for
all of these wonderful things.
So that's the story
of kinetics.
That's the story of kinetics,
but it's 11:35 and it's time
to start a new topic.
And now, we can erase.
Thanks.
OK.
So let's talk about
something else.
Let's talk about
What I want to talk about today
is another topic that
comes from the general area
of rate phenomena.
I want to talk about something
else in rate phenomena.
We're going to talk
about diffusion.
And that's from the general
class of rate phenomena.
That's why it appears with
chemical kinetics.
And what do I mean by
rate phenomena?
Rate phenomena means d
by dt is in the room.
All right?
We're looking at time,
domain processes.
You know, chemistry, before you
came into this class, you
probably thought, I know
what chemistry is.
Chemistry is chemicals
reacting.
That's what people think.
Isn't that what the ancient
Egyptians said?
khemia That's where the guys
knew how to embalm
the dead and so on.
It was about chemical
reactions.
We've been talking about
structure, properties, all
sorts of things.
Well, now we're talking about
rates of reaction.
If we want to run a reaction,
there's two things that we
need to move around to
sustain a reaction.
So transport of two important
quantities.
One is matter and the
other is energy.
We star something for energy.
As we just saw, the
thing doesn't go.
And if we starve it for
matter it doesn't go.
So energy in motion is
under the general
rubric of heat transfer.
But we won't talk about heat
transfer because we've only
got 14 weeks.
I'd love to talk about it,
but we're out of time.
So instead, we will talk
about mass transport.
And mass transport in solids
occurs by diffusion.
And we know what's critical.
For example, we know in the case
of the Hindenburg, the
Hindenburg didn't explode.
Why didn't the Hindenburg
explode?
Because there were 7 million
cubic feet of hydrogen, but we
couldn't get 7 million cubic
feet of oxygen to the site.
Because of the limitations of
mass transport, 2/3 of the
people walked off
of that vessel.
It was on fire, and many of
them died because they
panicked and they jumped
to their deaths.
Very few people were actually
affected by the fire.
So it's a good example of mass
transport, negating the rate
of what otherwise could have
been an explosive reaction.
So I'm going to look at a
simple example today.
And what I want to do is
look at the doping of
semiconductors.
You know, we've studied
Dave, could we cut to the
document camera, please?
So what I've got here
is I'm going to show
you a silicon wafer.
And the silicon wafer has
got some features on it.
So it's already been doped.
Oh, that's pretty, isn't it?
So cute.
All right.
So what we've got here, remember
this is the 8-inch
diameter single crystal.
So this was cut from a single
piece of silicon 8 inches in
diameter, about 2 meters long.
How did they make a
single crystal?
They immersed the tiny single
crystal into the melt and
gradually pulled the
single crystal out.
Sort of the way you can grow
rock mountain candy.
And if you're really careful,
the entire giant, 2 meter
length, 8 inches in diameter,
is one single crystal.
And then we take this and we cut
it with a diamond saw into
wafers, Each of them about a
millimeter in thickness.
And, of course, the width of
the saw turns into dust So
your yield [SNAPS]
right off the bat
is about 50%.
Because [SAW SOUND]
it's all gone.
[SAW SOUND]
And now what we're going to
do, is we want to dope it.
So how do I get the
boron in here?
We say, why don't we add the
boron to the melt, but what if
I want to make pn-junctions?
So I want to get some boron
and some phosphorous.
If I add the boron and
the phosphorous,
it then goes nuts.
I need to have p-type
against n-type.
So how do I get it in here?
That's we're going
to talk about.
We're going to talk about how
we make those features.
See those features?
Because if you're really good,
you start with those features
and you cut them up and
then you end up with
this, which is this.
This is a Pentium chip.
The amount of material science,
physical chemistry in
that device is absolutely
phenomenal.
What lies underneath this piece
of gold is absolutely
phenomenal.
It's what powers the
information age.
And it all starts with
this stuff here.
It's that simple.
So how do we get the boron in?
Dave, let's leave this up.
It's a pretty image.
It might soothe the natives,
so let's just leave it up.
By the way, that spider network
is all the gold wires
that are addressing.
It doesn't do you any good to
have a gazillion features
there but you can't get
information in and out.
So if you've got a gazillion
features, you need a gazillion
leads to take information
in and out.
That's very, very thin gold.
How do you do that?
Not with a paint brush.
It's all with this stuff.
That's why I teach you
this instead some
of the other stuff.
OK.
So now we're going to dope.
We're going to dope the
silicon with boron.
Number one point to remember--
we're going to dope the
silicon in the solid state.
We do not add boron
to molten silicon.
We're going to add boron
to the silicon
in the solid state.
So I'm going to draw
this wafer.
Only it's not to scale.
It's going to look more like a
hockey puck than a thin wafer.
Anyways, imagine it's this.
OK?
So this is the silicon wafer,
the silicon wafer on edge.
And this is where all
the features were
that I showed you.
So we're going to do is
we're going to try
to introduce boron.
We want to get boron into the
silicon, we're going to bring
it in from the surface.
So this is a silicon
wafer, which means
it's a single crystal.
It's a single crystal.
And we could use Laue methods
to figure out
which is the face.
Is that cut on the 0 1 1?
Is it cut on a 1 1 1?
And so on.
So now we're going to
dope with boron.
How do we do it?
We decompose diborane.
We introduce diborane,
it's a gas.
B2H6.
And we flow diborane over the
surface at some constant
concentration.
And what happens is that the
diborane decomposes.
B2H6 on silicon.
And I'm going to write
silicon with an x.
What's the x mean?
Crystalline.
Single crystal.
Make sure no one is thinking
this is being performed in the
liquid phase.
And this diborane decomposes
to elemental boron plus
hydrogen gas.
So hydrogen is a gas, and the
boron goes into the silicon.
Boron goes into the silicon
where it goes on to the
silicon sites.
I could just write a rate
constant for this.
We just studied kinetics.
I don't know.
What is it?
Second order?
You know, it doesn't have to be
integral order, by the way.
It could be of order 1.5.
Nothing is saying it has
to be integral order.
OK.
So now what I want to do is I
want to ask, what happens as
the boron goes in?
So that's the next question.
As it diffuses in.
So what I'm going to do is I'm
going to draw this little
cartoon here.
So I want to look at here's the
surface of the silicon.
So I've got a gas phase here and
I've got boron going into
the silicon crystal.
So I'm going to now get a little
bit quantitative, if
you'll permit.
And so it's going to
look like this.
And put it right underneath
here.
So this is x. this
is depth from the
surface of the silicon.
So this is the free surface
of the silicon.
And I start off with some
concentration surface
value, c sub s.
Meaning concentration
at the surface.
And that's fixed.
So cs fixed by B2H6
concentration in the gas phase.
So that's fixed.
Now, question is, what
does it look like?
The advance of the boron?
So this is now the
concentration of boron in silicon.
This is the silicon
crystal here.
So what does it look like?
Well, one possibility is it goes
in like this as a front.
See if I wait, goes in farther
and farther and farther.
That doesn't happen.
Sorry.
Take that off.
You know what happens?
Same thing we've been
looking at all day.
So now what's the question?
Question is, what's the
functionality of this?
Is this 1 over c?
Is this log c?
Is this some other
function of c?
I want to map this into some f
of c versus g of x so I can
get a straight line.
Why do I want a straight line?
Because I want to
be quantitative.
Because you are in charge of
designing a fab line and they
want to know what the resonance
time of a silicon
wafer is supposed to be at
billion dollars multiples.
You know, the units are in
billions of dollars.
So you don't want to make the
fab line any bigger than it
needs to be, the resident's
time any longer.
This is only way you're going
to be able to design it.
You have to understand this
because the design
specification is going to
be dope to a certain
concentration of a
certain depth.
So how long does it take
to get boron in?
You can tell me.
Set the concentration here
and wait 5 minutes,
10 minutes, 30 minutes.
Two companies.
One takes 30 minutes to process
the wafer, the other
takes 10 minutes to
process the wafer.
Guess which company is going
to be in business
two years from now?
It's not going to be the one
that takes a long time.
Hint.
So we need to know what
the rules are here.
And the mathematical
formulation was
set by Adolf Fick.
Adolf Fick, 1855, answered
the question, what is the
form of that line?
He's an interesting guy.
He was at the University
of Zurich.
And it's sort of like
the Balmer story.
Remember J.J.
Balmer was the school teacher
in Switzerland.
This guy was in Switzerland,
too.
Something going on there in
Switzerland in the late
eighteen hundreds.
So remember J.J.
Balmer?
He fit not his own data, he
fit the data of Angstrom.
Angstrom made the measurements,
Balmer fit the data.
Well, same thing here.
Fick did not make the
measurements.
He looked at some data that had
been taken back in 1833 by
Thomas Graham.
Thomas Graham had been making
measurements back in the 1830s
of gases diffusing through
porous membranes.
Or just say, through
membranes.
Obviously, if they
weren't porous
they wouldn't be diffusing.
Redundancy.
Department of Redundancy.
This is diffusing through
membranes.
So what happened was
that he modeled it.
And here's what he
came up with.
He came up with--
oh, by the way.
I didn't mention what he was.
He was a physiologist. He
was a medical doctor.
He just poured through the
scientific literature for
amusement, evidently.
OK.
So this is what Fick gave us
as the model for the data.
He gave us what we know as
Fick's First Law, Fick's First
Law of Diffusion.
And we'll just call it FFL,
Fick's First Law of Diffusion.
And we'll write Ficks'
First Law J.
J, which is the flux.
This is the unit of measure of
mass transport, the flux,
which obviously is the
mass flow rate.
We said this is mass transport,
so this is the mass
flow right of species i, OK?
And we're going to say in the
x-direction because things
diffuse in all directions,
right?
If I open a perfume bottle here,
the diffusion will take
place in all directions.
So I'm going to make
this one dimension.
So the flux is a mass flow rate
of i in the x-direction.
J sub i in the x-direction.
Remember we said the
Chemical Rate Law?
We said the Chemical Rate Law
was that the rate of progress
of a chemical reaction goes
as the concentration.
Well, Fick studied Graham's
data and he said, the flux
doesn't go as the
concentration.
It goes as the gradient
in the concentration.
That's how you linearize
those data.
So you take the concentration
gradient, which is dc by dx.
OK.
So that's the concentration
gradient.
Gradient in concentration
of i in the x-direction.
You could write this as--
make this vector--
but we're not going
to do that.
It would make it one-dimensional
here.
And the constant of
proportionality is d sub i,
which is called the diffusivity
or the diffusion
coefficient.
And puts the minus sign.
Why?
Well, you know things move from
high concentration to low
concentration, right?
So I open the perfume bottle,
the odor gets--
the odor, pardon me-- the
fragrance gets stronger as you
get closer to the bottle.
Things move from high
concentration the low
concentration.
So if I gave you this
concentration profile--
what's profile mean?
Profile means--
this is a concentration
profile--
if I draw someone like this,
this is head on, right?
And if I do the right view like
this, this is the profile.
Profile.
Side view.
This is profile.
Concentration profile,
obviously, the concentration
is higher to the left.
So things are moving
from left to right.
But look at the slope.
The slope is a negative
number.
So if the slope is a negative
number, but I want to get a
positive flux, I need to have
the minus sign in here.
Diffusivity is a physical
constant.
It has to be a positive
number.
So this is Fick's First Law.
I'll just give you the units
and then we'll stop.
So what are the units?
Well, the units in flux are in
SI units kilograms per second.
And we're going in one
direction, and so as we're
trying to diffuse into this
piece of silicon, we have to
normalize it per unit area.
So it's kilograms per meter
squared per second.
You know that concentration is
kilograms per cubic meter.
d by dx is 1 over meter, which
means then that the diffuse
coefficient or the diffusivity
has units of length squared
per unit time.
This is the units of the
diffusion coefficient.
And we'll get back to
business next day.
David, may we cut to the
slides again, please?
OK.
So I talked to you about--
oh, yeah.
There's all this.
You see they give
you a half-life?
Crazy.
Forget it.
OK.
There's the book talking about
activated catalog, da, da, da.
This is Fick's First Law.
This is the paper from 1855.
Go ahead. "On the Influence of
Diffusion" by Dr. Adolph Fick.
So the number one catalyst
in the world, number one
application is automotive
catalysts for exhaust. So
gasoline is octane.
C8H18, which we burn in air.
We burn it in air, we
make hydrocarbons.
Pardon me, we burn hydrocarbons,
which obviously
means the carbon goes to
CO2, ideally, and the
hydrogen goes to H2O.
But sometimes you get incomplete
combustion.
I already showed you that.
Maybe we stop it CO.
But remember, air
is 4/5 nitrogen.
So when you burn hydrocarbons
you also, at these high
temperatures, mix nitrogen
and oxygen and make NOx.
And is was actually the
precursor to smog.
So what we want to do is to
eliminate these imperfect
combustions.
So we want to convert the
unburned hydrocarbons.
There's actually some of the CH
compounds, volatile, then
don't get burned.
We want to burn those
to H2O in water--
pardon me, H2O in CO2.
The unburned CO has
to go to CO2.
You might say, but isn't
CO2 a greenhouse gas?
Yeah, it is.
But you know, given the choice
of carbon monoxide and carbon
dioxide, my advice is go
with carbon dioxide.
Carbon monoxide will
kill you at about
200 parts per million.
And then NOx, we
want to convert
that to carbon dioxide.
So GM alone tried over
1,500 catalysts.
Why GM?
Why not the auto industry?
Because the U.S. Government,
in its wisdom back in the
1970s, invoked the Sherman
Antitrust Act and forbid the
automobile industry to
collaborate in the search for
a catalyst. And since they
didn't understand the science
of catalysis it was
trial and error.
By inspection.
And it's a huge space,
trying things.
But they eventually found,
after 1,500 tests,
platinum-palladium works for
hydrocarbons and CO, and
rhodium works for NOx.
It's almost as though mother
nature said, I'll give you a
catalyst and it's going to be
the most expensive part of the
Periodic Table.
You buy this stuff at the
jewelry store, you see.
Furthermore, this is an
oxidation reaction.
This is an oxidation reaction.
This is a reduction reaction.
So if I told you I want you in
the same place at the same
time on a vehicle moving 80
miles an hour to conduct
simultaneous oxidation and
reduction reactions with no
intervention, you'd
say impossible.
They did it.
This is the power of selectivity
of the catalyst.
So this is an old diagram
from GM literature.
Now we have fuel injectors,
here, but fuel goes into the
engine, out to the exhaust.
There's an oxygen sensor,
which I'll show you next day.
Oxygen sensor measures what
composition of the output gas
is, sends it to an electronic
control module, which then
goes back into the carburetor.
And the catalytic convert
is right here.
And Dave, if you show
the document camera.
This is the monolith.
This is a piece of ceramic
because platinum and rhodium
and all of these other elements
are so expensive.
See, this thing's having
a hard time.
So we'll cheat a little bit.
We'll put this here and
then it'll focus.
All right.
So what you're looking at,
these are long channels.
And just to give you a scale,
this is about a half of a
millimeter.
This is about a half a
millimeter square and they go
all the way down for a length
of about eight inches.
And then the walls, the interior
walls, are coated
with a very, very thin
layer of platinum,
palladium, and rhodium.
Because these are expensive
metals.
And it's a surface effect.
So you get no value if you have
an inch deep of platinum.
The only stuff that works
is the free surface.
What you'd really like
is a monolayer.
But a monolayer of platinum has
no mechanical strength.
So you put the platinum,
palladium, and rhodium down on
a catalyst support. and this
stuff is made of a ceramic,
it's magnesia, alumina silica
that's been extruded like
pasta, and then fired.
The technology is absolutely
phenomenal.
Goes into this.
And then to get the
platinum-palladium-rhodium
they have a very
thin acid wash.
chloroplatinic, chlororhodic
acid, wash, little bit of
surface tension, holds just a
little bit of water, fire, out
comes the metal.
Just thick enough.
If it's too thick, dilute the
concentration of the acid.
But use that precious
metal sparingly.
Platinum hit $2,000 an
ounce last year.
$2,000 an ounce.
You steal a car, throw
the car away, and get
the catalytic converter.
So anyway, that's underneath.
That's what's going on
underneath the car.
And actually, I'm holding for
you the elements of clean air,
the catalytic converter.
But the catalytic converter
can't work unless we control
the air to fuel ratio,
which we have to do
with an oxygen sensor.
I'll show you next day.
And you've got to feed
it into a CPU.
If you don't have a CPU, it
can't make rapid feedback to
keep adjusting the air-to-fuel
ratio.
All right, Dave. Let's
cut to slides and
we'll get out of here.
So I'll show you what
else is in here.
OK, there's that.
So there's the old thing.
There's the engine,
da, da, da.
Exhaust, the control module.
And look, in the old days
they actually had--
they look like little
ball bearings--
cost of these things
was phenomenal.
So last thing, we had to
go to unleaded gas.
Unleaded gas was brought in
because the lead would be
broken down into elemental lead
because lead is volatile
as an oxide.
The lead alloys with
the platinum.
Turns it into a lead
platinum alloy.
Lead has no catalytic value.
Because if it did, we would
use lead and not platinum.
OK.
We'll see you on Friday.